the end is near credit run from it dusty
still arrives
the best thing about marble every single
movie has set the chessboard up for this
really tense standoff each character has
an environment that they fit in and it's
nice to move some of those pieces around
after we were lucky that I got to be the
one to go in infiltrate Wakanda cap
opens the door into childhood heart it
opens a place where he can trust
outsiders should we bow yeah he's a kid
what are you doing we we don't do that
yeah we're seeing what we'll kinda can
bring to the Avengers they need support
and help to deal with a very major
global threat and of course what Conda
and wakandans are the best to partner
with you buy in Wakanda now this is the
place where we should rally and try to
win this is a pretty amazing universe
it's just huge as the Guardians as Thor
and his people you know there's people
for more condos everybody's just
gathering together to defeat an enemy
it's pretty awesome so good on what
kinda good on us yeah we don't fight for
one less
we bought back in fact for all of them
being able to film after film tease at a
larger story really building these
stories up into a giant conclusion while
at the same time introducing an entirely
new direction for the future
hey everybody is Charlie happy infinity
war week you may have heard about the
new phase for movies the Kevin Feige
announced our in development some in
various different stages so while - an
updated phase four movie timeline but
some of the new announcements were
actually a pretty big deal so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
obviously this week is all about
infinity war I'll explain when my
non-spoilery reviews and all those
videos are going to be posting at the
end of this video so a lot of a really
cool really important stuff happening
this week but the biggest new things are
that they confirmed that there's an
eternal movie in development there's an
ova movie that they're talking about and
a Moon Knight movie so I always got lots
of Moon Knight questions but Nova has
been one of the other biggest questions
since the first guardians movie came out
why is it that we have the Nova Corps
but we do not have Nova himself not
really a phase four announcement but
Kevin Feige did say that they were not
planning on doing a big Hall H panel
during comic-con this year now that
doesn't mean that they're not gonna drop
any footage for Captain Marvel or
Avengers for it just means that they're
not gonna do a big Hall H presentation
because even though I haven't seen the
movie as of me posting this video this
morning it's implied that there's gonna
be a lot of destruction and The Avengers
will be destroyed almost by the end of
infinity war so it would be kind of
weird for them to celebrate everything
that just happened with a big Hall H
panel so they'll still have a presence
at Comic Con with all the normal stuff
there will still probably be some new
footage they just won't be like a big
happy celebration with all the Avengers
that are gonna be in Avengers 4 on stage
doing their big spiel because there's
been a bunch of press junkets happening
the past couple of days he also did talk
about integrating the x-men characters
in the MCU the way he talked about it
made it sound like he was intending on
just surfacing those characters in the
pre-existing Marvel Cinematic Universe
it's not like they're gonna be a
separate universe that only crosses over
every once in a while
so when you see MCU Professor X it will
be within this shared universe where the
people that survived infinity war also
exists like spider-man for instance
because we're know they're shooting
spider-man two this summer didn't really
provide a timeline for when that
Eternals movie when the Nova movie or
when moon night might possibly come out
but
like the updated phase four timeline
spider-man 2 is the only phase for film
that's gonna be released next year
because Captain Marvel and Avengers four
are the tail end of Phase three
spider-man 2 is the beginning of phase
four that next year 2020 is guardians
three it's the only movie tentatively on
the schedule for that but they did say
that they're working on a black widow
movie they're definitely doing black
panther 2 but Kevin Feige said that
they're still trying to lock down ryan
coogler and they're not gonna make black
panther 2 without him but they're
definitely gonna make black panther 2 so
everybody cheer ryan coogler on as he
tries to get as much money as possible
from Marvel because they did not lock
him down for more than one film so that
means he's gonna get paid for that
second Black Panther film but now on top
of that we have eternals Moon Knight and
possibly Nova so those other films the
recent ones he just announced could be
nebulous it could be tail in phase four
it could be sooner I think a lot of that
just depends on them finding the right
people the right actors if that comes
together faster they'll fast-track the
movies like spider-man and black panther
2 are there big priorities right now and
then whatever their next Avengers film
is going to be because there's gonna be
Avengers films till the end of time
every two to three years some of those
new films like Eternals for instance
might wind up being period pieces
because Thanos is a deviant he comes
from Titan the deviance or an offshoot
race of the Eternals it would make sense
that if his race the Titans are extinct
when infinity war picks up that you
would tell some of that back story with
this Eternals movie like this is where
they came from these are the things that
eventually led to their downfall
so like you saw Captain America 1 take
place during world war 2 tell the origin
story then it jump back to present-day
they could also do that with some of the
space-based movies too it's just that
we've only had guardians so far and even
though James Gunn has teased that will
be a lot of different looking
space-based movies eternals just sounds
like it's the first one that they're
fast-tracking the Nova movie is a little
more complicated because you know no
spoiler warning because I think it's
implied and all the infinity war
trailers Thanos takes the Power Stone
from the Nova Corps
he probably blows most of x' and are up
when he takes that so what does that
mean for the Nova cores future in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe if you're not
a big comic book reader there's
something called
and Arion world mind which is the
sentient computer that stores the
consciousness of every deceased member
of the Nova Corps they haven't
officially introduced that idea in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe yet but they
could use that if they want to move the
timeline forward with the Nova movie and
they want to do a Sam Alexander movie a
young version of Nova so there are like
three different versions that they've
introduced in the comics there's Richard
Rider the original version there's Sam
Alexander the young version then is part
of Sam Alexander story they say that his
father was secretly a member of the Nova
Corps but most of his story is told
through his son Sam as he's learning how
to be a nova but it's sort of a Spider
Man homecoming situation where you have
a really young version of the character
that doesn't know exactly how to wield
the power and has to get all this help
from older people so that's kind of
what's going on with the Captain Marvel
movie where you're telling her origin
story but there's already a pre-existing
version of the character Marvel who sort
of passes the mantle on which who knows
you know what James Gunn might want to
do with that character if they're gonna
do that movie because a lot of the
Guardians movie feels like it plays
towards a more family audience so I do
think it's a strong possibility that
they do Sam Alexander also he's been the
most recent version of the character in
the comics that people are familiar with
but Kevin Feige tends to be a
traditionalist when they tell origin
stories like that so anything's up for
grabs let me know in the comments do you
want them to do original Richard Wright
or Nova straight up origin story for him
set in the past or do you want them to
do an OVA movie set in present-day with
Sam Alexander and sort of incorporate
his comic book story as far as Moon
Knight goes they could go any number of
different directions obviously that
would be an earth-based story it might
not be r-rated though and I think that's
a big hold up for people like they were
hoping that it would become one of the
new Netflix series but because Disney is
developing their own new streaming
service a lot of people are wondering
where all the new shows that they
develop are gonna go like will Netflix
get any new different characters or is
it just gonna be the ones that they have
right now so just a reminder Adrian
Martinez you're the ticket giveaway
winner from this past weekend but there
is a new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway I'll name the winner when I
post my non-spoilery infinity war review
tomorrow night
I believe I'm allowed to post it around
p.m. or so so I think it'll post right
after my flash episode video normally
posts so Tuesday night non spoilery
infinity war review then inside that
video I'll explain the rest of the
schedule for the week so if you haven't
already be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
but click here for more new infinity war
and click here for my West world episode
1 video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you